Tại sê đối xe chắn cho đường đi còn thích tức người khác.
Mình không biết là đều đều không một nè.
Nào nó vọc.
Mình làm việc nhỏ ngọt.
Bộ bảo nấu xe đông qua bản thân thác còn đi.
Em thấy người ơi, anh cũng đoạn này.
Bộ ra đình trên đời.
Sáng 1, 2, 3 mục tức mùng một tích.
Tại viện trường biết, tại sê con mổ chẳng đối gần như chếm cho phần đường đi rồi và nhạc.
Sẽ gần cơm ra hành trình không thể vượt qua nên có ý nhất chủ sê tục sình đấu gọi để có thể dí chuyển.
Tuy vậy, người này không đồng ý, sau đó sể ra cái pháp,
thách tức, thích ăn đấm không kém ông thành như chủ động thành hùng.
Tại sê xe cắn cơm ra cho rằng xong xe cố, anh đã phải quay đầu đi đi vừa khác.
Sư việc đã được báo cho cụ quan công an để dài quếc.
Lưu ý, đường là ngọt sống thường nhỏ không đủ 2 ổ tổ chế nhau.
Bây vệ, các tại sê cần có ý thức chung, đối xe vọn gặng nhiều lối cho xe khác,
nhất là giếp lế, tất, lối xe tăng đột biến.
Hí sể ra xong đột, cần bình tính đối thoại thay vị hành hùng.
Mò hành vi chuẩn động hành hùng người khác dụ là lối xor gì đều là xa trái.